We are your heroes we are
here to serve and protect you
but that doesn't mean
sacrifices won't still be made
who are you maeve
there's no way we can restore the grid if
we don't get that flash drive to the tower
it's been a good run no we are the one and only
true justice
guess this means we're breaking up
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
boys season 3 trailer video obviously they're
making a lot of justice league snyder cut jokes
in a marvel avengers endgame jokes so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
episodes are literally dropping this weekend
that's right the first couple of episodes
are dropping i'll be doing videos for all
the episodes this season just like previous
seasons this brand new trailer is basically
meant to be like a parody of the trailer for the
movie that they were shooting throughout season
two the dawn of the seven the title being a
parody on batman v superman dawn of justice
but the way they used that movie within the
narrative of season two and what's going on
in season three it was more of a parody of the
justice league snyder cut because even zack snyder
got in on the joke when they released this trailer
a little while ago like they call it the board cut
that's meant to be pj burns director character who
was shooting the movie throughout season two and
zack snyder was commenting on the post saying
oh you know i can't wait to see your vision be
realized just joking about the movie obviously
in this fake context because it's a fake movie
in the same way that real life directors real life
actors were talking to him when the justice league
snyder cut came out back during 2021 like we can't
wait for your vision to be realized we're so happy
about this for you and obviously the movie is
meant to be very cheesy within universe it's
like this big marketing campaign for vot they're
using it basically to sell their products like you
see all this destruction all over the city and
they're yelling about getting this flash drive
to the tower but right behind them you see this
prominent ad on the bus for a train soft drink
turbo rush which they actually shot a fake ad for
in one of the earlier trailers like this is the
ad for his fake soft drink which is meant to be
kind of like an in-universe version of red bull
and because everything that vought does is meant
to be this big marketing ploy like they're really
just trying to sell more products that's the
reason why superheroes exist the reason stan
edgar said that they developed compound v because
they were more of a pharmaceutical company they
weren't a company about superheroes none of what
they did had anything to do with actually saving
the world it was just about selling more products
back during world war ii vots started out as a
scientist for the nazis obviously with stormfront
we learned about that backstory but what happened
is that he wound up defecting to the united states
and they started bought america but they had to
decide what to do with his compound v because it
was successful like they could actually create
legit superheroes jensen echols soldier boy is
like the americans first example of trying to
make their own superhero but within the context of
the universe they're actually using him a little
bit more like the stormfront character in the
comics back during world war ii they're saying
that he actually comes from the vietnam war era
like much more recent war because they kind of
moved the timeline up in the boys universe but
they're calling him sort of like the prototype
for everything that they turned homelander into
like they used him as this big symbol for peace
and he was sort of like a work print for what a
superhero could be in all the powers that they
gave him so by the time they got to homelander
their formulation was just so much more advanced
and the way that they used him in this big
marketing push as a superhero to sell more
products became way more sophisticated obviously
very insidious too for instance they actually just
released this in-universe parody ad of a 1970s
anti-drug psa they used his soldier boy character
for back when he was active with the payback
team because your super power is just saying no
obviously the irony there is that vought is
literally a drug company a pharmaceutical company
so all these characters soldier boy are juicing
like they're all taking hardcore drugs talking
to the public saying don't do drugs drugs are
for losers just meant to show you how fake what
they're actually doing what they're telling to
the public actually is so just to be clear all the
saves that they do all over the world when they're
talking about sending superheroes to a city to
get rid of crime really that's just a marketing
push like that's all just a ploy for them to sell
more products they made a big joke about this
during season one in reality all the superheroes
that they give compound v2 are terrible and
don't really know much about their powers at all
even homelander isn't totally sure about all the
powers that he has he's nearly indestructible
he's meant to be the most powerful person on the
planet almost nothing can kill him but i think the
idea is they want to introduce the concept that
ryan could potentially kill him like a superboy
versus superman think ultimately in whatever their
final season winds up being their version of an
end game but the other big joke with their whole
dawn of the seven movie here their justice league
snyder cup movie is that they've reworked it and
used special effects to make it look like they
always planned on making stormfront the secret
villain of the movie when they didn't shoot the
movie that way at all like they probably shot
extra footage and then just use cg replacement
to replace some random actors face to make it
look like storm front just further trying to
capitalize on what happened during season two the
public finding out about the truth the stormfront
and all the terrible things that she did but them
also trying to capitalize on that and save face
by blaming her for literally everything bad that
had happened up to that point if it wasn't clear
too the showrunner said the storm front is
still alive that's one of the crazy things
about the compound v superheroes especially the
more powerful ones like stormfront and homelander
is that they're really really hard to kill so even
though she's like the anakin skywalker burnt toast
version after revenge of the sith on mustafar
she lost her leg she lost her arm she's just
like this crispy piece of toast they basically put
her on ice the same way that you see jensen echo
soldier boy basically put on ice and cryostasis
all these years because vat didn't know what to
do with them this is like their version of making
someone go to ground so to speak like okay you're
becoming a bit of a problem we don't know what
to do with you you're too powerful to control so
we're just gonna put you to sleep literally and it
sounds like butcher with his temporary superpowers
like he has the temporary version of compound
v that's all green when he gets super powers he
accidentally winds up releasing him and finding
him like wait a minute soldier boy where you
been this whole time what's going on what's this
all about when it really looks like he's there
trying to destroy this vault lab without knowing
that soldier boy has secretly been kept there
even though there's this whole running story line
with victoria newman that seems really fascinating
like she seems kind of like a double agent in
their ploy to get someone inside the white house
because she is literally based on vic the vice
president character from the comics who was the
former vice president of vaude the title of the
first episode is payback which is one of the teams
from the comics they're meant to be a big avengers
easter egg from the marvel comics like literally
paying someone back revenge the revengers make all
the revengers jokes that you want but obviously
they changed the storyline just a little bit for
the tv show the way they're using them on the tv
show is that payback was the team that he was on
back during the 1970s like they have this classic
1970s looking poster with their team on it and
you see the black noir was actually on the team
with him so black noir has been around all these
years just the same issues that it seems like he's
much more willing to be stan edgar's puppet within
the seven if you didn't watch that animated tie-in
series that they did the boy's diabolical there
were a couple of short animated episodes only
a couple of them were meant to be can they did
a homeland or episode showing what happened to
him during his early days on the seven when he
was a much younger superhero getting into this
big accident black noir winds up helping him out
and so they wind up being bros that's why i think
they've replaced the black noir comic book plot
whatever the end of their story winds up being
with the ryan plot but all this footage early in
the trailer where he's talking to cameron on this
fake news network that voc controls is basically
like their mouthpiece for just telling the public
what they want them to believe he's promoting this
movie dawn of the seven that they're getting ready
to release in universe talking about how he fell
in love quote unquote with the wrong woman is
that so bad like it's meant to be them addressing
the repercussions of what happened at the end of
season two there's that funny scene of him looking
into the camera all crazy like saying i can't wait
for the public to see the real me but the actual
joke is that there is no real him he's just like
this fictitious cobbled together backstory that
vought has created for the public the really funny
way that they said that they're using jensenak's
soldier boy character too it does seem like they
gave him a huge power upgrade like there's this
weird bomb effect that goes off when you see him
lose control of his powers you see the flashbacks
where it seems like he also loses control of
himself his emotions the same way that homeland
or loses control it just goes completely crazy
on everyone just killing everything in sight
jensen echols said that they're kind of using
him like this really old man out of time captain
america parody because he is literally a captain
america parody he gets stuck in the ice just like
captain america gets stuck in the ice and has to
re-acclimate to present day during the avengers
movie when he comes out but he's meant to be
like the douchiest version of captain america you
could possibly imagine because the version in the
comics is more like a patsy for homelander he's
like this puppy dog type of character and this
is they're not really doing that with the jensen
access character like they are doing the herogasm
probably one of the most wtf things ever committed
to film but they're not going to do the crazier
stuff from the soldier boy homelander plot
during the comic book version of herogasm so
it'll be fun for people who aren't super familiar
with the boys to learn about what's going on with
that it'll be fun to try and talk about without
getting the video demonetized too if i was able
to do videos for game of thrones for eight seasons
without getting any of those demonetized then i'll
probably find a way to do a video for herogasm
without getting that demonetized too make a video
about something but challenge mode so what'll
happen on friday is i'll post my video it'll
probably be for the first three episodes i believe
they're dropping episodes one through three and
then it'll be weekly after that but it'll be eight
episodes total for season three just like it was
for previous seasons so if you have any questions
about what's going on during the episodes just
write them below in the comments and i'll try
to add them to my episode videos but that video
will post friday morning just like normal everyone
click here for my full ob1 kenobi episode 3 video
star wars easter eggs and click here for my brand
new mandalorian season 3 trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!